♪♪
David Attenborough:
Dawn, on the shore of the
ancient Tethys Sea.
♪♪
David Attenborough:
And hundreds of tiny turtle
hatchlings are on the move.
♪♪
David Attenborough:
Instinctively, they race towards
the safety of the water.
♪♪
David Attenborough:
They've been spotted by a
hunter.
♪♪
(Exhale)
(Sniffing)
♪♪
David Attenborough:
A young T-Rex, still sporting a
juvenile's feathery coat
♪♪
David Attenborough:
He's got the killer instinct.
♪♪
David Attenborough:
But his problem is...
inexperience.”
(Mild growl)
(Water noise)
David Attenborough:
This could take some time.
(Waves crashing)
♪♪
David Attenborough:
A full grown T-Rex is the
planet's most powerful predator,
(Heavy exhale)
♪♪
David Attenborough:
but today, he's just being
Father.
♪♪